[Musique]
durant des siècles les nôtres sont
restés cachés sur terre
mais elle est ténèbres nous ont retrouvé
prime
il en va du destin de tous les êtres
vivants
[Musique]
une écrou arrive
tu as amené un humain ici moi je suis
personne je vois rien j'entends rien je
vois même pas qui me parle là
ce n'est pas notre guerre
Optimus nous devons nous faire confiance
pour protéger ce monde que nous
partageons
il est si grand que ça ce mec
il mange des planètes donc ouais
carrément plus grand qu'une planète
à la fin
tout ce à quoi vous tenez
sera englouti
il y a peut-être un autre moyen de
sauver notre monde
vous n'avez jamais rien affronter de ce
genre
qu'il vienne
[Musique]